Yeah.
As we saw in the last lectures is human spread out across the planet,
the encountered different diseases and that resulted in genetic variation for
disease resistance,
but they also encountered different diets that contain different nutrients and
different toxins is a result,
patients very genetically in their ability to metabolize drugs because of their
recent evolutionary history.
The area of science that studies this is pharmacogenomics and it's idea
basically is to analyze how much does individual human genetic variation affect
our ability to metabolize drugs.
It arose because we got a very serious signal in the late 1950s and
antidiarrheal drug called Cleo all was tested and found safe on Europeans and
then without testing it on Japanese,
it was released in Japan and it killed some hospitalized,
many possibly an interaction with environmental problems in that post World War
II environment,
but very likely primarily because the Japanese different genetically from the
Europeans.
Okay.
Individual and Inter ethnic variation and Cytochrome p four fifties these are
called sips and in an asset deal transfer races in 1977 and 1953 in both cases,
that was initially found through adverse drug reactions.
So patients suffered and people wondered why and did detective work,
okay,
no,
we have information on human genomes and that's being used to find the legals
and to predict variation in drug response using more sophisticated computer
modeling techniques.
Yeah.
The same gene products that metabolize drugs are also involved in processing
toxins in food.
In fact,
that's why they initially evolved.
Okay.
And they process smoke and all the byproducts of other carcinogenic substances
and are thus involved in the mechanisms that elicit cancer and shape the
evolution of its resistance to drugs.
So this is not just about how well the patient's process drugs,
it's also about how likely are they to get cancer and if they get it,
how likely are we to be able to treat it?
Okay.
Now patients vary in their drug response for many reasons.
And only some of those reasons are genetics.
So they vary in drug response because they are different ages,
genders,
ethnic background,
weight,
family history,
what the time of day affects it.
Uh,
their microbiota affected.
And also there can be placebo effects.
Those are clinical reasons.
And then in the environment,
it depends on how well nourished they are,
what other drugs they might be taking because there are drug drug interactions,
there are chemical exposures,
their lifestyle,
they are a drinker or a smoker,
uh,
and how compliant they are.
All of these feed together to produce a particular dynamic or kinetic of the
drug in the body and that leads to a particular intensity and duration of drug
response which can have a therapeutic effect and can also produce an adverse
reaction or toxicity.
There are two main classes of enzymes that are involved in drug response,
the first of which are the cytochrome p four 15 these are heme file late
proteins and their significance in processing toxins and now drugs is indicated
by the fact that these are families of genes that exist in many copies and the
they evolve by repeated duplication.
They are proteins that are bound to a heme group and their color and their
absorption peak,
which is about 450 nanometers.
Give them their name.
That's why they're called cytochromes
and humans.
We have 57 of these chains.
They are bound to the endoplasmic reticulum and to the inner mitochondrial
membrane.
They mediate our response to toxins and to steroids as well as other reactions.
Yeah,
there were 23 genes in the first three families and they account for about 75%
of human drug metabolism.
Yeah,
we're going to focus just on one of them.
It's called sip two d six cytochrome p four 52 d six.
This is what a representative cytochrome looks like.
It has to heme groups here in here and life is using these heme groups to
manipulate oxygen precisely.
So you can think of Cytochrome p four 50s as being surgical specialists in
dealing with oxygenation reactions,
which in chemical formula will look like this.
You'll have some molecule and you can add in the presence of a cofactor,
uh,
an oxygen to it.
You can then produce a hydroxyl radical and water.
Now cytochrome p Two d six is clinically important because of its variation.
It was discovered in a case in London in 1977 there was a volunteer who had a
hypotensive response.
So low blood pressure,
too deep,
too deep.
Brisa Queen.
That's an antihypertensive.
And then another evolve volunteer in Bonn had increased side effects,
uh,
taking spartina which is anti arrhythmic.
So both of these were related to variation and sip two D six.
It is now known to be involved in adverse or decreased drug effects for many
drugs.
Antiarrhythmics,
antidepressants,
Dura,
elliptics,
anti and journals,
opioids and Pheta means and anticancer drugs like Tamoxifen.
So this is an extremely important mediator of the patient's ability to respond
constructively to drug therapy.
The percentage of poor metabolizers,
you know,
the jargon in,
in this area of science as a PM for poor metabolizer,
very strikingly among ethnic groups.
So here's some ethnic variation and sip two d six the ones here in this gray
region are not functional.
Basically what you can see here is that people who are of African American
ethnicity or most of them have a much higher frequency of uh,
Elio,
one then do people of East Asian ethnicity and American whites also share that
with Africans.
However other Europeans have lower frequencies of that then do east Asians.
So there's quite a bit of ethnic variation.
And and the the point here really is individual humans differ tremendously in
the probability that you'll have a variant of this particular enzyme.
Now why is that important?
Well,
it can vary from two to three copies per individual.
In metabolizes about a quarter of all of the drugs on the market,
it's polymorphisms influence about 12 to 14% of all drug metabolism and that
includes antidepressants,
antiarrhythmics,
anticancer drugs and analgesics.
Duplications reduce the efficacy of drugs that treat a rhythmia,
Alzheimer's and heroin addiction,
but they improved Tomoxifen and treatment of breast cancer.
As a result of those facts.
The drug industry now tries to avoid developing drugs that are metabolized by
this enzyme because they cannot predict how individuals will react to it.
It has a direct impact on drug rehabilitation to other cytochrome p four 53 a
four and two B six o have variants that cause great very individual variation in
how much methadone you need to give a patient to achieve a given blood
concentration of that drug to obtain up methadone plasma concentration of 250
nanograms per milliliter.
A dose of Methadone is low as 55 milligrams per day or as high as 921 milligrams
per day can be required in a 70 kilogram patient.
That's more than 16 fold variation in dose and it's caused by variation in these
genetic polymorphisms.
It depends on which of those genes that particular patient has.
There is a another very important set of enzymes that are involved in drug
metabolism and those are the NSF.
He'll transfer races.
There are two of them in a t one and an 82 they activate and deactivate both
drugs and carcinogens and they are active mostly in the liver site is all,
so they are part of the metabolic machinery that makes the liver is such an
important part of cleansing our body.
Okay.
Different Elios combined to produce rapid intermediate or slow acetylator
phenotypes.
They were discovered in 1953 in patients who are being treated for tuberculosis
with a drug called ISO Niacin.
The drugs that they metabolize include sulfonamides many other drugs and the
metabolites of caffeine,
so people vary in their reactivity to coffee and tea because of genetic
variation.
In an NSF deal.
Transfer races.
Yeah.
Europeans and North Americans are about 22 to 26% fast to settle.
Laters and East Asians are 67 to 74% fastest subtle layers.
So ethnicity is giving an indication,
but not a precise read on the probability that a patient will be either a fast
or a slow acetylator.
Okay.
This is what the molecule looks like.
It's movable parts are in red.
That indicates the the part of the molecule which is going to be adjusting to
the substrate.
Yeah.
There is important genetic variation associated with cancer susceptibility.
There are two major associations.
One is that the impact of an environmental toxin on cancer risk depends on which
genetic variant one has for an asset transfer race and the other is that the
ability of a cancer cone to resist chemotherapy depends both on the genetic
variant it inherited from the germ line and shares with the other cells of the
body,
but also on what somatic mutations it has acquired during the development and
the clonal evolution of the cancer.
Okay.
Here are a few examples of how an asset he'll transfer races interact with the
environment to determine cancer risk for bladder cancer.
The Nat two slow acetylator acetylators are about one and a half times more
likely to get bladder cancer.
And those that have a combination of any two slow with nat fast and current or
ever cigarette smoking are nearly three times 2.73 times more likely to get
bladder cancer.
So here are the interaction effects between the genes and between the genes and
the environment are both important
for colorectal cancer.
One of the most important cancers that hits people as they age and a t one fast
acetylators have significantly higher risk of colorectal cancer than did the
slowest scintillators and smoking intensity increased colorectal cancer risk
among carriers have both in 81 and eight and an 82 fastest laters
yeah.
For pancreatic cancer,
one of the Nastiest,
uh,
cancers and one that can produce devastating metastasis.
And 81 polymorphism interacts with dietary Mutagen in intake and increases the
risk of about 2.2 to 2.5 times.
And it does so in men but not in women.
So you can see that the genetic variation is interacting both with environment
and with gender to produce different profiles of cancer risk,
both because these molecules are involved in detoxification of things that could
induce cancer,
but also because these molecules are involved in how well the cancer cells
themselves can resist chemotherapy.
There is also genetic variation as I've mentioned to chemotherapy,
so all cells in the cancer share the genetic capacity to process drugs with the
abilities that the healthy cells in the body have.
And so patients can begin life with different potential responses down the line
to chemotherapy for reasons they inherit from the germ line.
However,
cancer cells also accumulate many somatic mutations,
some of which may affect their ability to metabolize drugs and thus to resist
chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy applies very strong selection to competing clones and it rapidly so
selects resistant clones.
Some of that resistance is probably attributable to mutations in the genes that
are coding for Cytochrome p four 50s and in sotl transfer races.
Okay,
we can use genome wide association studies.
G was to discover genetic variation for adverse drug responses.
Here it seems to work pretty well and it seems to explain a bit more than we can
when we use g was to explain disease resistance.
The reasons for that are not yet well known.
Yeah.
And what we can see is that if you have a clinical problem like mio toxicity and
the drug involved is a Staton in this case Sinvastatin then g was his found they
particular gene where variation is influencing that particular reaction.
This is also true for efficacy of treatment to a viral infection,
uh,
for treatment with Anacor and Adeq anticoagulants and for others.
So the point is that we now have fairly good high tech means of identifying
particular genes whose variation is associated with adverse drug response.
And that gives us hope that in this particular part of medicine,
identifying individual variants is going to bring a clinical payoff.
So to summarize,
individuals vary in the illegals that process drugs and environmental chemicals.
If they cannot process a molecule rapidly enough,
it will build up and can act as a poison.
Cancer cells also very,
and their susceptibility to chemicals is a cost for some of the evolution of
resistance to chemotherapy.
Knowing the genetic constitution of an individual and have individual cancer
clones can improve treatment outcomes and can reduce treatment risks.